Textcat was the name of the R package that Corey
used. We'll discuss R packages in the next video and what
they allow us to do. For the second question, the
automated system captures between ten tweets to 20 tweets a day.
For each of the tweets, the system will recommend that
whoever sent the tweet file a report. Now, for this last
question, we accepted any text answer here. I thought that
the most interesting part was that Cory showed the open source
R code classifier on GitHub. GitHub is a repository for
sharing code. You can learn more about GitHub by following the
links in the instructor notes. It's the most popular repository
for open source projects and it's really easy to get started.